Police gunned down the alleged killer Cherif
Chekatt....in Strasbourg's Neudorf neighourhood.
The 29-year-old grew up here.
Security forces finally caught up with him
on Thursday evening, a full two days after
the attack on the city's popular Christmas
market.
This individual matched the description of
the person wanted since Tuesday evening.
They arrested him.
The moment they tried to arrest him, he turned
around and opened fire.
They then responded and managed to shoot him
downCherif Chekatt was already known to police
for his long criminal record and radical Islamist
beliefs, before he indiscriminately open fire
near the Christmas market.
But he managed to escape.
Security has been heavy in Strasbourg since
then.
Now people say they're relieved it's finally
safe to go out.
Everybody is quite happy to know that the
killer has been finally shot.
And I think now the city and life can keep
going on in Strasbourg.
The Christmas market is reopening on Friday.
France remains on high alert in the wake of
the large number of terrorist attacks, which
have shocked the country in recent years.
Tuesday's attack has left Strasbourg in mourning,
but determined not to give in despite the
latest terrorist outrage.